we looked at recurrence relations also
known as reduction
formulas within the context of a
logarithmic example
and also an exponential example but it's
appropriate we'll also have a go at a
trigonometric example so
have a look at this where you have some
integral being defined as sine x to the
power
of m you're probably familiar with this
idea of some function
raised to a power and that power is
nothing gets reduced
over and over again at each new step of
integration so
there are a couple of things worth
noting with trigonometric
integrals like this that are slightly
different to log and exponential
so we'll point those out as we go along
now there is actually a fairly natural
way to divide up sine x to the power of
n
into a product a pair of different terms
a pair of different factors
that can be done with a regular
integration by parts and the most
natural
splitting i suppose you could call it is
between sine x
and then sine x raised to the power of n
minus
1. if we go ahead and do this and think
about this carefully
identifying what the u and the dv are
are not too dramatic
or not too dramatically difficult i
should say in terms of u
and dv remember if you think about dv
you're going to need to integrate it to
perform integration by parts
so out of these two which of them is
going to be easier to integrate
clearly it's going to be this one the
whole point of this being a bit of a
mess is why we're in this
problem to begin with so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to set this being to
you
in fact i'll even write that right here
we'll make this one u
and that makes this one d v so let's
have a go
at doing the sort of side integration by
parts a bit that will feed into
back into this main line of working if i
set let's see lizzy if i set
u to be sine n minus 1
x then my derivative will be
just be careful we've got a use of chain
rule that we need to be cautious about
so
first i will deal with the outside so
it's a function that's been raised to
the power of n minus one
so that power comes out the front and
then i reduce the power
by one there's the outside derivative
and then i also need to do the inside
derivative in this case the inside
function is sine
x so therefore the inside derivative is
cos
x okay so there's my u and my
d u i'll now move on to my dv and
my v i chose dv to be sine x
just watching out for my signs here um
my plus minus signs not my
trigonometric signs uh when i integrate
up into v
i'm going to have negative cos x if we
were differentiating you'd get cos x but
we're not differentiating we're
integrating to go here
okay so this is really great i've got my
uh
when i think about you know doing my
integration my parts over here
i've got my u and my v those are going
to be my terms
out the front so here comes mmm i'll put
that minus side out the front which you
can see
from this v here and i might as well put
the cos x there
while i'm at it so even though it's in
reverse order
there is my uv and then i'm going to
subtract
the integral of v d u now there's my
v term right there and then here's my
mess of a d u term but i do notice if
you have a look closely
i've got a cos x term here and another
cos x term
here so they're going to combine i'm
going to get a close squared so it looks
to me like
doing my vdu i'm going to get let's see
here
n minus 1
cos squared x and then i've got my
sine to the n minus 2
x the other thing to notice is that i've
actually got um this minus sign that
i've not included here
i haven't left it oh i have left it
right to the very end so that i can
collapse it with this minus sign here so
if they cancel and they give me a plus
all right so this is promising but we're
definitely not out of the woods yet
we've got this
new integral here that i'm going to have
to deal with and you can see i've got
this cos squared term
and this psi next term i should have
also included how my constant
integration that's
uh or my variable of integration that's
pretty important
you can see that i'm going to get this
cos squared term if i use the
pythagorean identity that's sine squared
plus cos squared equals 1
therefore i can say that cos squared i
can replace with 1
minus sine squared and i can also take
this constant out the front of the
integral
as well so that's going to simplify some
terms for me
what have i got out the front well this
minus cos x
sine to the n minus 1x that hasn't
changed
i'm going to put this n minus 1 out the
front as promised
and then i reckon i need to shuffle this
over just so i have a bit more
breathing room over here might even make
it smaller because we don't need it
anymore
in here within the integrand i'm going
to put 1 minus
sine squared x sine
n minus 2 x dx
what can i do with this well you can see
if i look at all of these terms
that kind of are unchanged out the front
like so
once i dive in you can see i can
actually break this into two
integrals you can see i've got this
let's use this color
this integral that comes from the 1 and
the sine
n minus 2 x so that's going to be
something that is going to fit into this
recurrence relation because it's of this
same
form sine x to the power of some
particular value in this case
n minus 2 and then when i have a look at
combining
the sine squared or a minus sine squared
i should say along with this
sine to the n minus 2 x this looks very
familiar it's
sort of the same trick that we pulled
here it's going to go back to if you add
the indices there
sine x the power of m so let's do this
one
step at a time first i will have the
integral of
the 1 times sine to the n minus 2x so
that's just going to be
sine to the n minus 2x here's my first
integral
and then i'm going to subtract over
again
excuse me don't forget that you've got
that n minus 1 still hanging out the
front from
here because that's applied to both
integrals so as i split this integral
into 2
they both get this n minus 1 coefficient
integral of and then my signs you know
are going to
combine together i'm going to have
exactly n of them so sine
and x there we go okay now
this looks like a mess but i've finally
got this in terms of new integrals that
are in terms of sine x to some power
and that's exactly what this whole
recurrence relation is going to be based
upon so i can start making
some substitutions here and here for i
with the appropriate subscript
right so you hit once more you've got
all of these bits which are unchanged so
i'm going to just
duplicate them at the front and then
what comes next well
when you have a look at this term right
here that's going to be
i of n minus 2 because it's sine x
raised to
that particular power then i've got this
minus
n minus 1 there i'll leave that minus
sign rather than factorizing and you'll
see why in a second
and then what i've got here is by
definition what i started with
that right there that is i
n there we go now what is all this equal
to
this is all equal to i n and that's the
thing that i'm trying to find
i need to change that to be the subject
whereas i can see currently
there's an i sub n on both sides of the
equation
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
add this entire term that's why i left
it as a negative
to both sides that leaves me with n
minus 1
i n here plus i n
and then everything over here all of
this
is left as is let's change it all black
we
can leave it like that done okay at this
point we are so close
you can almost taste it right you can
see here on the left hand side
you're going to have n lots of i n and
then you've got
-1 lots of i n but hold on a second that
minus 1 lot
is going to interact with this positive
1 lot so they're just going to cancel
with each other that leaves me with n
lots
of i n on the left hand side on the
right hand side i'm just going to
switch the order here just because i've
got a minus sign at the front of that
cos
x term so minus seems a little more
natural there
sine to the n minus 1 x and all that's
left here is divide through
by n to make i sub n the actual subject
of the equation so
i've got i sub n equals there and then
i've got divide through by m
there's my n minus 1 on n and then
here's my 1 on n cos x
and so on oops and easy
there we go so um i want to know a
couple of things
firstly we had to use the
pythagorean identity as we were going
through this right right and here so
this is all the way back from the
advanced course it was really important
because it always allowed us to
turn this cos squared back in terms of
sine squared and this constant term
that allowed these integrals to get back
in the form of these i
sub ends back in the recurrence relation
language we were talking about
secondly you also noticed um like we did
the very first time before we even had
the uh language of recurrence relations
you had something
almost identical to the original
integral except in this case it was
multiplied by a coefficient
appear on the right hand side so then
you have to add that over to the other
side
and and deal with the left hand side and
then lastly coming out of the fact that
we use the pythagorean identity you
might notice that this particular
recurrence relation or this particular
reduction formula
um it's i guess you could call it second
order it doesn't just go back one step
to an integral
one less uh in degree or in power it
actually goes
two and that's because of the
pythagorean identity being about squares
of particular trigonometric functions
so there you go this is how you do
develop the recurrence relation for
sine x to the power of n the last thing
that i just wanted to mention before we
leave off of
recurrence relations involving
trigonometric functions is that you can
get
recurrence relations for integrals of
trigonometric functions raised to a
power
even without integration by paths
getting involved
let me explain what i mean here right
integration by parts is the most common
way in which recurrence
relations are created because um when
you do the
um you know this is the this is the
integral of u
dv uh udv within here rather and then
what you create
is you can see this uv plus integral of
vdu so
the integral that comes out here vdu
creates another integration process
which
you know sort of gives birth to this
recurrence relation but because of
trigonometric identities
as you're about to see particular
integrals don't even necessarily require
us to pull out you know pull out
integration by parts
let me give you an example of it if i
said to you let's integrate
tan x to the power of n what would we do
now what we could do is we could try a
similar trick to what we did before
and see where it leads us there's
nothing wrong we're giving that a go
however one of the things you might
notice after having given that a play
is that actually there is a simpler way
to take advantage of
our knowledge of trigonometric
identities and are just our
straightforward like knowledge of
extension one integration to be able to
handle something like this
without integration by parts being
necessary let me try
and illustrate so you saw last time when
we did sine x to the power of n what we
did was we put out a single sine
x and then we had all the rest of the
sine x's they were n minus one of them
right now here to use the pythagorean
identity and get it b
to be useful to me i'm actually not just
going to pull out one tan x i'm going to
pull out
two and maybe i've left enough bread
crumbs for you in terms of your
understanding of
calculus and trigonometric identities
then you might see why pulling out two
of them
is going to be particularly useful to us
so here comes two of the tan x's
and that leaves n minus two of the tan
x's
uh over in the rest of the integrand
there okay so
uh just like in the previous one i'm
gonna pull out the pythagorean identity
that i used except i've got tans uh
instead of signs so um a dirty little
secret that i have is that i never
remember
the versions of the trigonometric
identities for
relating the pythagorean identities
together i just remembered this one
and then what i do is i divide through
by whatever is appropriate in order to
turn this
into the version that i need so for
example to get tens or ten squares
rather out of this
what i do is i divide everything by cos
squared you can see what that does
is it creates this tan squared term here
and you get all the rest of these terms
on the right hand side so
what have i got a tan squared there
because i said 10 squared what i meant
was cos squared okay so what do i get
this is going to be tan squared on the
left hand side i just get one there
and then the reciprocal of cos squared
is sec squared i
i don't have tan squared plus one i've
just got tan squared so i'll subtract
one
from both sides now maybe you're now
starting to realize why this is going to
be useful
to me you can see here i've got i've got
this sec squared x minus 1 then i'm
going to substitute up into
here so i've got the integral of oops
let's just do some brackets here
sec squared x minus 1
tan of n to the power of 15 and minus 2
x dx okay now again similar to with
my sine x the power of n example uh what
i'm going to do is i'm going to break
this into two pieces right
i've got the bit that has this x squared
in it times this and then i've got the
minus one of this so let's have a go at
breaking that into two pieces
i've got 6 squared x tan
of n minus 2 x dx and then
noticing that there's a minus sign right
there it's going to go minus
integral of 10 to the n minus 2
x dx okay so what have i got here right
well let me start with this second term
i'll do this backwards right let me
start with the second term first
you can see this is just this is the
recurrence relation i'm already set up
right this is 10x
to some integer power in this case it's
n minus 2.
so i'm shortly going to replace this
with i
sub of n minus 2. so that part is ready
and good to go
what about this part over here well if
it's not quite obvious yet what's going
on here
think back to your extension one
integration and the kinds of things you
would have to do with this
admittedly we're kind of in extension
two lane because i'm not specifying what
you need to do here that was a bit of a
clue
but this is going to be reverse chain
rule with an unspecified
substitution in this case if i think
about u
being equal to tan x what will d u
on dx equal and in this case and this is
why i use the pythagorean identity the
way that i did
it's going to give me sec squared x
which is exactly what i have here
so just tightening that up to make it
easier for me to put into
the integral up above you can see that
means that du
can be thought of as sec squared x dx
so this term here appears right here
there's the sec squared x and the dx so
that's just going to be replaced by d u
and then this is my tan x term raised to
a particular
power so i guess what i'm getting here
is the integral
of u to the n minus 2
d u that's that part completely
substituted minus you can see over here
this is my recurrence relation that i
mentioned before
so this here is a really straightforward
integration it's a
polynomial integration it's completely
algebraic right i'm just going to raise
the power
divide by the new power and then while
i'm at it i might as well complete my
substitution
back into what i had before namely in
terms of
tans and x's so let's have a go i'm
going to have
u which is 10x
it's going to be raised to i don't know
why i wrote the x already
it's going to be raised to a higher
power so there's me increasing the power
by one
i'm then going to divide by my new power
and that's the whole integration that's
it
minus i to the n minus 2. so you can see
here
this recurrence relation i created let's
just zoom out here
without any use of integration by parts
and that's because for this particular
version here the pythagorean identity
it hands you back the derivative of the
inside function
tan x so therefore you're set up for
reverse chain rule
so the other thing you should notice is
again because you use the pythagorean
identity this is a second order like
it's two steps back
on this recurrence relationship not the
not just one step
so that's a common feature of
trigonometric
integration processes that there's a
link but you have to go two times
to get back to where you started